des premier regard on sent qu'il se
passe quelque chose c'était à paris à la
closerie des lilas automne 99 c'est ça
ouais un brouillard de cigarettes et
deux yeux bleus qui le transperce comme
des là comme des lames de poignard c'est
ma première vision de renault plat tout
de suite se passe quand même un petit
truc pas spécialement je vois juste ses
yeux je me dis ça se trouve il ya un
éclairage sur lui qui m'a fait voir
cette image un petit peu je compte mais
enfin choquante qui m'a marqué mais
oui je le rencontre pour la première
fois à ce moment là mais sans plus après
bon vous voulez comment quand vous
mettez finalement semble assez le grand
amour ouais voilà après une traversée du
désert renault va sortir son album de la
renaissance boucan d'enfer
fabien lecoeuvre et c'est un carton
incroyable 2 millions d'albums vendus
c'est énorme c'est toi qui l'a remis sur
la voie de la chanson ce qu'on parle de
ces femmes vrai qu'ils sont derrière des
grands artistes moi je je je suis
j'étais juste présente j'ai pas j'ai pas
à prendre ce bénéfice là je vais pas
apprendre grand chose comme bénéfices je
vous avoue voilà on est sur ce sujet je
vais vous répondre mais j'ai pas énorme
à vous répondre maintenant parce que non
c'est sûr c'est surtout sur sur ses
démons tu sens tu dis tu dis que dès le
début de votre relation tu sens que ses
démons sont pas loin et tu as des mots
très forts avec lui on ne sait jamais
tout son être ses humeurs son
intelligence sa mémoire est indexé sur
la quantité d'actes d'alcool qui
couvrent qui coule dans ses veines qui
court dans ses veines c'est ce que tu
dis dans le livre
oui oui c'est sûr que c'est
c'est un sujet c'est
c'est quelque chose qui est qui est
compliqué au quotidien mais mais après
c'est une décision que la personne prend
elle-même et l'entourage peut aider moi
j'ai aidé par la présence mais mais au
sens dans le livre que tous les jours tu
craignais le moment où il allait être
est il se remettrait à boire il se
mettrait à boire dans la journée ou est
ce qu'on ressent ouais effectivement moi
je ressentais que même quand tu ne
devais pas il dépensait et c'était
compliqué parce que j'avais toujours
cette épée damoclès
mais mais mais mais voilà je n'y suis
pour rien finalement quoi il changeait
vraiment du tout au tout quand il était
tueur boyer qui voilà qu'il n'était pas
bien qui sentait pas bien ouais je
sentais qu'ils dépensaient beaucoup et
je pense que l'alcool pour lui c'est
comme un neuroleptique finalement ça lui
permet d'oublier c'est la base de ses
soucis c'est peut-être pas finalement
l'alcool son problème quoi alors est-ce
que tu essayé de trouver les mots pour
voilà pour lui faire penser à autre
chose ou pas du tout je n'arrêtais pas
way j'essayais de effectivement on
parlait beaucoup et on le fait encore
aujourd'hui d'ailleurs et mais c'est en
lui et c'est à lui de se prendre en main
et c'est à lui de prendre cette
responsabilité
c'est difficile de tout mettre sur les
sur les épaules de delà de la personne
qui accompagne tu dis dans ton livre
cherono l'alcool le pastis ça devient
régulièrement un problème est un
problème qui a des répercussions sur
votre couple
au passage que 10 tirs inventé ce
concept d'apéro une belle merde oui car
ce mot je sais ce qui m'attend une ligue
achi une dispute une déception c'est sûr
qu'il ya à dire dans ce que parce que tu
écris la dent dans la vie à la - en fait
tu tiens il ya des
y a des moments quand j'étais confronté
à ça ou c'est vrai que l'apéro le mot
apéro m
moi ça me saoulait couailhac il faut dès
maintenant on va prendre un apéro non
pas l'apéro mais puis après tu sais il
ya tout le monde a envie d'être celui
qui va faire passer un bon moment à
renault donc allez viens tu bois un coup
mais justin puis moi je suis à côté puis
moi je passe pour la chiante coiffure
mais vas-y romane en temps mais laisse
le boire un coup quoi ça va et ils
savent pas tout ce qu'il ya derrière
avec un verre comme lui dit très bien et
là il a il a toujours d'aider des
phrases comme ça qu'ils sont super je
suis contente juste et à mes quatre
chinois fait c'est il me dit inverse
trop disent c'est pas assez
ça c'est trop et après tu passes le truc
et ça a gâché votre cou
ce que vous dites là des dix buts en
liga chine disputent une déception de sa
cacher votre coupe bien évidemment un
petit peu oui
bien que vous vous seriez rester encore
plus longtemps sentis avait pas eu ce
problème
ouais c'est ça qui a fait que ça c'est
terminé entre eux oui sacré c'est tout
ce que ça engendre tout ce que ça
provoque qui effectivement vous faisiez
des moments heureux et vous saviez qu'il
y avait cette épée de damoclès en fait
au dessus de votre tête et de la sienne
en fait parce que lire assez de
mouvement il d'en avoir envie de d'aller
boire et que et moi je vais être être
victime en fait voilà je vais je vais
être voilà je vais pas me cacher ma
soirée on est petit puis quand il ya un
petit garçon au milieu un petit peu
compliqué quoi je passe d'une pièce à
l'autre en donnant une compote aux bébés
en disant bon
vas-y reste là que j'allais voir renault
pour les inciter c'était pas très alors
il ya une anecdote dans livres à
l'époque de votre mariage en 2005
écouter ça c'est vous vous trouvez
d'ailleurs une règle vous dit arnaud six
jours sans alcool est le 7e jour il se
permet un verre ou deux sauf que
rapidement vous voyez toute la semaine
il pense au septième jour bah oui
c'était quoi c'est à dire que il y là il
arrivait à faire les six jours ou bien
tu rêves il y arriver mais ça y est le
7e jour mais il est hyper costaud en
fait ils leur constat et il y arrive à
sans problème et puis des fois il buvait
le septième jour musée web
en fait j'en ai même pas besoin ça sert
tout bien les boules mais à
mais bon il y avait des fois où il y en
avait besoin
oui bernard montiel vous avez dit
également romane que vous avez
l'impression d'avoir deux enfants à la
maison malone notre fils est également
lui donc c'est ça qui était compliqué
aussi pour vous sans doute g5 et
compliqué parce que
il était un petit peu amoindri
effectivement c'est avec l'alcool ça ça
aide pas à avoir le tonus quoi donc
j'avais j'avais un j'ai deux enfants
romane vous avez tout essayé parce que
vous avez sais quelle autre technique
pour essayer de les noyer
essayez de gueuler donc d'être tout le
contraire de ce que je suis c'est à dire
gueuler vraiment vous êtes un carnet où
ils disent ça suffit maintenant si l'on
voulait pas dire tu vas nous faire ça
mais je vais vraiment faire bien sûr et
vous disais quoi il me disait
en fait je n'écoutais pas c'était à la
fin et je m'entendais pas n'entendait
pas mais mes cris de détresse quoi je
m'attendais pas
ouais alors c'est vrai que vous avez
essayé d'autres techniques escape est ce
qu'il ya des solutions qui peuvent réel
pouvait réellement marché ou pensez pas
du tout est ce que quand celle ci est
bon quand ça c'est fini entre nous
est-ce qui vous a parce qu'il n'a pas
essayé devait revenir et de dire voilà
je vais vraiment arrêter ci est alors
mal j'y croyais plus et reboosté faut
ajouter n'y croyait plus vu qu'en fait
quand je quand je me suis mise avec lui
je n'étais pas au courant de ce que de
ce qu'ils étaient l'alcoolisme est tous
à l'adopter finalement je me suis rendu
compte que les promesses et tous et vous
avez vous avez y ait cédé plusieurs fois
quand même à la décrue plusieurs fois
été déçue même fait des lettres en
disant je te jure que moi j'y croyais ah
oui et au bout de combien de jours ça
reprenait non mais des fois il tenait
longtemps mais enfin longtemps c'est
relatif mais vous pouvez tenir six mois
là dernièrement il a tenu un an et demi
c'est quand même et ça ça fait il paraît
qu'il boit plus depuis 18 mois c'est
magnifique c'est sûr ça wafa ya une
petite un petit moment de rechute mais
mais la sacem pour gagner un septième
jour mais ça va mieux ça y est
complètement ça va mieux vraiment
vraiment passion on est content parce
que c'est vrai que j'adore ordonnée bon
ben ouais tout comme tout le monde mais
vraiment beaucoup et j'ai eu la chance
de rencontrer c'est un mec vraiment que
j'aime vraiment beaucoup oui quel est
l'âge justement moi j'aurais voulu
savoir ce qu'il pense de votre présence
ici et du livre alors le livre i là
j'avais peur en fait tout le livre
pour moi c'était le sujet tocci parce
que j'avais pas envie de faire un livre
sur renault je parle de beaucoup
d'autres choses et à manger
il fait partie de ma vie c'est le père
de mon fils on a été mariée on y rester
on se connaît depuis 20 ans et et
c'était complètement normal et ça aurait
était faux de parler quoi je suis
heureuse de parler de ça c'est une très
très belle histoire et j'avais peur
parce que évidemment je me livre aussi
et puis on est passé par un divorce est
forcément ces moments là sont pas
toujours chouette il ya voilà je fais
pas un livre de revanche et tout ça mais
je dis les choses et est en fait il m'a
dit il m'a dit moi je savais pas que tu
écris aussi bien sa voix suave et il m'a
dit mais en plus j'ai même appris des
trucs que je savais pas franchement
bravo
je vais donc y valider c'est au creusot
à valider votre coeur ouais c'est vrai
mais il aurait donc j'étais super touché
jeudi xavier vous aviez la pression
c'était important pour moi oui vraiment
et je je lui ai dit j'ai écrit un livre
il m'a dit ne fait pas ça on va que de
parler de moi et ça va être chiant pour
toi donc j'ai dit écoute je vais le
faire ça me fait du bien j'ai besoin de
regarder en arrière pour pouvoir
ça et il m'a dit bon bah fais comme tu
veux
et puis
et puis en fait voilà il et il est
content aujourd'hui pas bien le coeur
c'est une démarche intelligente en tout
cas cette ce livre et puis on se
reconnaît renaud aussi suffisamment
aimant et suffisamment attentif et
généreux vis-à-vis des autres mais ce
qui est important de rappeler c'est le
rôle de romane
parce que quand on est la femme de tout
le temps ça c'est épuisant
alors faut savoir qu'elles ont sonné
malville étaient visibles non mais ça on
le leur on le dit jamais assez c'est à
dire pour le grand public au départ
quand une femme arrive dans la vie d'une
star quelqu'un pour renault c'est tout
de suite une croqueuse de diamants
exactement toujours et puis après on
s'aperçoit après on la compare à la
précédente épouse mais aussi leur dit
alors l'hôtel était mieux ou alors il
était moins bien sale aller mieux c'est
assez délicat et finalement sa
personnalité la raison elle est
complètement gommé tout ça alors que
exactement on en a souvent parlé
ensemble c'est à dire du à saleilles tri
bien elle compose bien il suffit
d'écouter les ses albums
c'est à dire que mais d'un seul coup il
ya cette ombre à côté de renault et lui
le sait intelligemment site est un homme
brillant aussi ça il sait bien qu'ils
qui te fait une ombre il le sait bien
que c'est compliqué c'est pour ça qu'ils
craignaient ce livre à mon sens mais
c'est une démarche intéressante ce que
vient de dire fabien vous en avez
souffert des gens qui disaient qu'ils
ont pu dire voilà elle n'est pas sincère
parce que tout moi j'oublie tout y a
plein de gens comme vous étiez dans le
biais de la musique tout le mondial a
plein qui disaient oui c'est parce
qu'elle veut faire de la musique
r honos elle veut se mettre est-ce que
vous en avez souffert de ça qu'est ce
que vous répondez à ces gens là j'ai
souffert de ça et en même temps il m'a
énormément aidé et je suis infiniment
reconnaissante et avis mais c'est vrai
que j'ai commencé à faire de la musique
bien avant de le rencontrer mon premier
album il avait été fait en amont avant
que je le rencontre et c'est pour ça que
c'est si parfois super injuste quoi de
d'être juste cantonné à la fille qui
arrive dans sa vie et qui profitent
g
et j'ai toujours j'ai en fait juste
avant de signer avec lui j'avais la
proposition tignes et à tulle c'est
fabien avec les scorpions d'acord et les
gros culs en fait j'avais des
propositions et pour moi ça me semblait
normal et logique de travailler avec la
personne avec qui
bien sûr je vivais et est gelé un petit
peu payés parfois qu il ya eu un il ya
les deux versants c'est ce à quoi c'est
le temps le temps répare les choses oui
oui rodez oui et je vous ai écoutés par
est alors il avait dit que je qui me
turlupine
c'est pas le problème et c'est pas qui
boit c'est pourquoi il boit et 10 ha ha
ha et vous n'avez jamais su pourquoi il
buvait moi c'est vrai qu'une bonne à
l'être après ccc ses propres démons il
est pétri de doutes des doutes
ouais et puis les très sensible donc il
a il et il a une grande perception mais
pas au passé mais que renault c'est une
un peu comment notre vie comme lyonnais
est décédé mais qd est indétrônable dans
le coeur des français c'est vrai c'est
vrai pourquoi pourquoi il veut autant
vous voulez et vous laisser il veut
s'échapper encore arrêté mais qui veut
s'échapper lui même ce qu'il était
heureux et go way et il n'arrêtait pas
de dire je suis heureux c'est indécent
je vais le payer un jour et il a bien
aidé le destin quoi